I have to ask you a couple of months ago
you're surprised you're rollin cabaret
and it's this big deal and then one
night Shia LaBeouf gets arrested at the
show and I just want to hear from you
what the hell happened oh well you know
I think he was he was really messed up
and and obviously and he did that he
apology you know didn't apologize but
you know he explained it last week yeah
and I just feel I thought you did that
was a very good thing but he was just
wasted and he was wasted from the second
he walked into the thing so there was an
atmosphere in the when I went down to go
onstage and start the show everyone was
freaking out because there was a you
know someone who seemed to be a crazy
person shouting and so you knew that you
could feel it in the air you could sense
oh yeah very much sir there was a
LaBeouf quality to the air and then what
did he actually do he grabbed what did
he do he granted me he granted because I
they walk into the audience at one point
introduce syllables and as Michelle
Williams and then I walk into the
audience and go up to the back and come
down and as I walked past him he was at
a table on the end of a roll and he
whacked me and I know but but you know
and then other things you know he kind
of he was he was smoking and he was just
but I think you know what I I thought
when he did that thing last week we've
all done things where we've been out of
it I just messed up and I just think
it's you know no everyone has to deal
with her in such a worldwide scale and I
thought it made a very good recovery and
he did say that the reason he did it was
that I was a sexiest man he'd ever seen
so you gotta go with that
you